welcome back 6 16 is the time it is
being called the largest
the world's largest boxing book right
here detailing some of the greatest
fights and fighters in history so it's
entering the ring so to speak for a
chance to be in the guinness book of
world records carl fowler is here the
ceo of opus carl welcome great thank you
for having me so
what makes this book so unique despite
the fact that it's super heavy there's
nothing else like this no it's it's
taken taken about three years to put
together with the wbc it tells the story
of the greatest fights of all time okay
and one of the things that makes it
really unique is that we pulled together
20 about 25 wbc champions across weight
divisions across eras and asked them to
choose the top 12 fights of all time and
the twist was to rank them from 12 down
to one wow so there's a real sort of
competitive spirit going on in the in
the context if you're a fan of boxing
you won't see anything like this ever no
this is for this right here you say
that's from a belt yep this is an
original belt buckle from a from a wbc
championship belt uh again which makes
it a little bit a little bit special and
autographs yeah who are these folks so
what you've got here is there's about
currently and we're still going there's
about 50 uh champions that have signed
this cover the reason is this is copy
number one
it's a limited edition of 100 copies
this is copy number one and we're taking
it around the world
asking champions to sign the cover and
then at the end we're going to auction
uh this copy for children's charities
with the wb beautiful yeah
90 pounds all right hold on it's a big
book
you got to try no absolutely nate oh
that's not bad two people can do that
easily okay we got this yeah we got this
because we want to take a look at the
inside and uh carl you're telling us
that folks have a chance to come see
this book yeah so
the great thing is that the nevada
boxing hall of fame in induction weekend
is happening here in vegas and so we're
gonna be taking it there uh over the
weekend for fans to come to come and see
so these are some of the posters too
from some of these incredible fights
from over the years wow wow
oh you just happened to open
so there's uh number 12. so that was
voted number 12
of all time of all time
oh man i remember some of these so this
is going to be where this event uh so
this is at the uh mandalay convention
center okay wonderful and and folks can
go and see it uh they can come here to
get in yeah it's it's there open to the
public uh car over the weekend thank you
so much wish we had more time to look at
this and talk about it but this is
hopefully you guys get into the guinness
book of world records yeah it's a
90-pound book
it's getting a little heavy over here
folks let me just uh all the way from
the uk brought this across the pond we
appreciate you coming in today this is
really oh there it is
is that number one
that's somebody's number let me just
show you the number one before we if i
can there's the boxing cards for the
rounds a lot of these things haven't
been seen before
listing over here come on
thank you so much
yeah it's really heavy it really is
scary